another thing that dr wright isn't  allowed to do at the scp foundation  pretend that  scp-963 is a joy buzzer for those who  aren't in the know scp-963 is the  medallion that you'll always find on dr  bright's person it's an indestructible  vector for his essence his very soul  anyone who touches it suffers immediate  brain death and dr bright's  consciousness is transferred to their  body so naturally when dr bright is  feeling mischievous it's not a very  responsible prank to treat  scp-963 like a joy buzzer considering it  will kill its victims instantly it's  like making a whoopee cushion filled  with nerve gas or a fake stick of gum  that's actually plastic explosives